weekly video game chat show every
tuesday at 2pm pacific right here on
videogames.com or if you're watching
this on twitch.tv forward slash gamespot
or you're watching this on demand on
gamespot youtube and all those
some videos pop up on weird things right
like amazon and
snapchat snapchat yes chat snapchat
facebook video aol chat rooms that's the
one
i was thinking of like there's like an
iowa video player or like dailymotion
i've seen some game spots stuff pop up
on it doesn't really pop up in odd
places yeah because we have some deal
with like yahoo where they that's what
it is more stuff around yeah it just
turns up what bumble bumble yeah it's a
dating app oh you can totally find us
there i thought it was like like a
crunchyroll alternative or something
yeah it took me years to realize that
was an actual i thought it was like a
food yeah you would think you're gonna
get delivered nice sushi yeah no no no
you get animated
oh is it really uh maybe you can sign me
sign me up we're not sponsored by
questions
i know
because we are a podcast as well if
you're listening to this uh the lobby is
now available on itunes and also we have
the rss feed out there so if you have
another um podcast program you like to
use uh gobble it up there in fact i'm
gonna keep
what
what's so funny about that it's mildly
funny
wow i just love the word gobble gobble
gobble gob gobble it just makes me think
of cards against humanity i'm not going
to say the cards but
right i think i can imagine perhaps
where that's going uh yeah but if you
can please review and write us on itunes
that'll be super great to get us up
there in the new and notable um if if
there's some reviews up by today's show
you we need to hit a certain threshold
before they like publish the reviews uh
so if there's enough by the end of this
show then i'll read out what's there if
there's not then i'll do it next week uh
so yeah if you can go in there and
review and rate us that'd be super good
and of course subscribe
every week uh
an hour of us chatting about video games
this week
justin haywald's here i am for a while
for a little bit i have to run to catch
a flight very shortly after this why
where are you flying going up to vegas
you know for a fun weekend sure yeah so
the vegas on a wednesday always fun our
the dice conference is going on which
you might have heard about on gamespot
it's mostly
usually not a lot of big news coming out
of it but it's an interesting show
because it always has
huge developers giving keynote addresses
and just talking about how they make
games and like their philosophies behind
stuff too the big guys this year are of
course going to be kojima and guillermo
del toro very interesting famous game
maker guillermo del toro yeah we're also
going to get todd howard coming to talk
about fallout so it's a really cool show
to watch and we'll be doing some
interviews with those guys at the show
peter is going to be going in to talk to
kojima himself great peter brown here as
well yeah you're going to dice as well
tomorrow though uh yeah i'm going to go
tomorrow and prepare myself with a good
night's sleep before i wake up in the
morning and talk to hideo kojima that's
going to be really cool yeah then we're
going to hit the strip and yeah you know
do the vegas things yeah
circa circus cirque du soleil tropicana
yeah make go to the venetian and get
freaked out by the daytime thing on the
inside that is so weird it is really
challenging i did it after like my first
time being in vegas and it was like a 13
hour flight or whatever from from london
and it was night time but it was day
time the next morning where i was and i
walked in and it was daytime there and i
was like what's going on
uh we've got a bunch of stuff to talk
about in today's show uh we're gonna
talk about zelda in just a second with
you folks fallout 4's expansion packs
and we're also going to talk about the
division beta which is opening up again
this friday if you're on pc and
playstation 4 a day earlier if you're on
xbox one uh peter you hear us we're
going to talk about street fighter 5
sort of status of that review uh we're
going to get eric in for that because
you literally have to run and get a an
airplane uh pretty soon so to that
effect let's jump into it so i want to
talk about zelda but first
a little bit of news it just broke
i guess right before we went live uh
black ops 2 3 there's this weird like
starter pack thing they're doing on
steam now just want to briefly talk
about it so for those who don't know
this is a 15 sorry 14 99 15
multiplayer only slice of black ops 3.
there we go that's the releasing on
steam it's kind of been like something
people have suggested might happen for a
while i was talking to andy before the
show apparently the call of duty
campaign and multiplayer have been two
separate executables on pc for years uh
so you can get this it's only got ranked
multiplayer doesn't have any zombies or
campaign doesn't have any like custom
games any of that sort of stuff but 1499
it's limited on you can only buy it from
either today up until february 29th so
they're like testing this out and then
you can upgrade if you want for 45 bucks
call of duty
yeah upgrade 45 bucks for 300
we've been talking about that happening
for a while because it just seems to be
where this is going you have people who
exclusively play multiplayer i mean
there's a reason that call of duty black
ops 3 was still the biggest selling game
for january yeah like it's still
something that sells really well on the
power of that multiplayer experience
highest selling game on this current
generation of consoles as well and some
people still love that story experience
like i i enjoy playing through a game
and getting a quick slice of story and i
enjoy that more usually than a
multiplayer thing
and being able to separate those out
like this is a chance for them to test
that out like are people going to be
interested in doing that especially now
like after the game's been out if
anyone's been on the fence and you just
want to get in and play multiplayer with
your friends that's a really low barrier
to entry for that thing
it's kind of a smart way to do that to
also avoid any criticism of doing this
when the game releases and making that
sound kind of crappy exactly it's
interesting though because it is like a
precedence as well where they've now
decided to do it so now next year
everyone's going to be looking to see if
they do it at launch which they probably
won't right like that seems like uh i
don't know like if this is really
successful i can see this being the
launch strategy yeah here's here's the
way that we're we're going to deliver
this because there are so many other
multiplayer centric games that are
coming out even at full price like um
overwatch which is a multiplayer game
there's not a single player story with
that you're going to get this and you're
going to play multiplayer and that's it
8 million people sign up to that beta as
well so yeah super popular sure we're
not talking about street fighter
no many people are trying to get online
with that at the moment um i also had a
quick look because this um i believe is
only is a pc only deal i'm pretty sure
um i looked at it on steam to see where
call of duty uh where blops3 ranked
within like the sort of where's ever
everyone's playing at the moment it's
down in like 20 seconds so perhaps this
is a situation where look we've got the
most popular game on consoles at the
moment it's maybe not it's maybe not
doing like there's other there's plenty
of first-person shoot i mean team
fortress two it's free to play i know
but it's like number two global
offensive no sorry team fortress number
four global offensive number two like
even gary's mod is still there number
seven so like maybe that gives them an
in that way i guess if you grow the
player base on pc then chances are more
people will buy it the next year do you
play call of duty on pc no no i don't
know i like to check out the campaign
and i try to jump into multiplayer
before i realize like yeah i still don't
really love this experience so it's
weird for me it always like i'm a i
played all the classic qualities on pc
and i love first person choose a pc but
for some reason blops has always just
been a console game i dive into the
campaign for a while sometimes complete
them play some multiplayer and then jump
off again well i mean part of that might
be hurt by the fact that it does come
out every year we have these other
shooters that are very
focused on upgrading the experience that
you have whereas you can always count on
there's going to be a new call of duty
every year and so it's it's like madden
or any of the sports games like you they
have a dedicated fan base who know what
they're getting into they're going to
buy this every year and for a lot of
people that's probably the only game
that they buy or one of two or three
games they buy in a year yeah super
popular and one of the questions here
just looking into the chat uh burgers
yeah wonderful what's the highest
selling game this generation uh while
the activision
i guess the numbers came out they had
their call last week and three of the
four games of this generation high
selling games are theirs and number one
is blops three interestingly enough i
guess the install base is finally in uh
yeah interesting i've just like it broke
just before we came out so i said i
mentioned it so if you have any thoughts
uh in the if you're watching this live
or watching us on the man let us know
what you think will you be picking this
up for 14.99 you've only got two weeks
to do it uh let us know anyway zelda
it's an anniversary this game came out
a long time ago 30 years ago and they
don't see far far away yeah
japan
uh yeah it turns 30 i guess this week
sunday you know simultaneously making a
lot of people feel very old and also
stirring nostalgia in their in their in
their bosom as it were um i didn't grow
up playing zelda games my first one was
actually uh i guess the gamecube was so
phantom
finding i was about to think yeah did
you find a phantom
glass wind waker sorry wind waker was
the first uh first uh zelda game i ever
played which is the one that holds up
the best like when you look at it like
graphically these look really good yeah
they made this cel-shaded graphic and
like at the time like we all derided it
as being this kind of crappy looking
kitty game like this this isn't zelda
that i know but now when you look back
at it you're like this still looks
amazing like that cell shading was such
a great idea for making a long-lasting
game it was crazy because the trailer
they showed for like what the gamecube
could do with zelda was the more
realistic like twilight princess
art style then they came out of left
field but yeah it's it's great it's so
different and it stands out uh 30 years
so we're obviously going to make a big
deal about it on gamespot there's a
bunch of really cool features going up
later on this week we're obviously going
to do it because obviously i mean
pokemon's a week after that yeah it's
just that's what's going to be now it's
going to be
the
anniversaries after anniversaries but
like not many games have the same
staying power of like 30 years like it's
such a long long time you think about
those early nez games you think about
like we were saying beforehand about all
the crappy ones like the the philips was
a cdi
games that released like they had some
it was a misstep but that was a misstep
that was giving it to another developer
right and it's not that they didn't ever
do that again because you had like
oracle of uh say the oracle of agents
seasons and those were done by
completely different development studios
capcom but it made them really distrust
american developers for a while i think
so do you think that's what is the
staying power of a franchise like this
like for 30 years to keep that quality
bar is it just that nintendo were super
protective of their of their games and
they just do right by them i think they
were able to identify what people liked
about the original um and i think they
learned a lot about that from the second
game because it was so different uh and
i think those two games combined
informed somewhat of a formula for the
series that nintendo has pretty much
stuck to for the most part um and even
if they deviate and do something a
little bit different with some of the
more experimental games like uh four
swords and the like they still always
come back to the one that everyone knew
and loved and in doing so they you know
they're giving people what they want
really and then they innovate once in a
while so that's everyone yeah they do
that great job of having a core
experience like no matter what when you
get into it you know there's going to be
a link there's going to be zelda there's
almost always going to be ganon but
they're able to to experiment in ways
that nintendo does so well and they do
the same thing with mario that each of
those games feels fresh and new in
exciting ways while still keeping that
core here's the theme and you get the
music and you're like oh this is a zelda
game and i was so excited to be in this
character again it's kind of this weird
thing where mario is like the
quintessential 2d platformer experience
and then when everyone else tries to
make a 2d platformer they can't just
make mario they have to like do
something fresh with it whereas mario
kind of just has this like nice column
of of this like traditional gameplay
that people know and zelda's almost kind
of a similar thing where it's it's it's
like every video game you start off as
this low powered character and then you
collect things and you go adventuring
places you find new areas and you get
more better abilities and they've almost
like cornered the market on this sort of
this thing that just works so good for
video games so then they can i guess
iterate in different ways without losing
too much of that
core gameplay again it's also how they
tinker with hyrule itself because hyrule
is always somewhat familiar like yeah
it's a kingdom sort of like a medieval
kind of a feel to it like in a way still
very fantasy but it also changes quite a
bit over time as well and even the sort
of like the laws of
you know physics that define that world
also change it uh
yeah it's like they're just really good
at sort of taking that thing that
everyone knows like you were saying the
core and just twisting it a little bit
to keep us interested and they do
something that i think final fantasy is
like square tries to do with final
fantasy where you have a core idea like
this is magic and these are people who
are going to explore a world
but i feel like they over the years
they've changed so much that it's almost
unrecognizable to someone who played the
original final fantasy yes where zelda
is very recognizable
you're in not only the same character in
the same world it's like now i'm just in
this world that's put into 3d and that's
something that's very like for for me
like having grown up with it like i get
into this world and i understand it
immediately whereas and someone who's
getting into it for the first time like
they understand this in a whole new way
but in a way that relates to them as
like here are the game experiences that
i've already had and they're a lot of
fun right yeah just like madden um a
bunch of great comments coming through
here on the twitch chat on gamespot chat
and munchchomp says it just had so many
standout moments in ocarina of time no
other game in the franchise really had
that story hit uh after it uh for you
guys what were your favorite zelda games
ocarina of time obviously the first 10
out of 10 on games spot back in it was
1998 i guess that's a lot of people's
favorites yeah for me it's always been
majora's mask like majora's mask took
the ideas of zelda and put it into an
adventure game rapper like i love
adventure games having grown up with
like old pc adventure games sierra lucas
uh sierra okay but weirdo it took those
it took those ideas and like made it
into a 3d world where
the purpose was still like you're still
getting stronger you're still collecting
items and weapons and you have the great
combat and music of zelda
but it's more about interacting with
people and exploring and talking and
trying to figure out this world it's
like the perfect adventure game and i
think the 3ds version just made that
even better like being able to explore
things and figure out what you need to
do and where you need to go like it was
such an improvement on that so for me
majora
uh linked to the past which is is
difficult because i really love the
original zelda so much that was the one
i grew up with and
as a young kid i didn't really know how
to do how to like complete the game but
i enjoyed the adventure but a link to
the past was when i was kind of like
confident enough to like take a video
game understand it see it through to the
end and i still find the art style
really charming i still find
the the two different worlds like the
light in the dark world very interesting
because it's the same place but
different and i think it did that at a
time when it wasn't really i think
yeah no
um
like i remember you you were getting
through that and you think you you beat
the game like really early on like oh
i'm here i'm gonna beat the bad guy and
i save the princess like holy [ __ ]
there's a whole other world and you go
on a crazy trip and you're in like the
apocalypse like no wonder you like
yourself
um yeah and you know even again i think
that game established for the series
like when you explore and you run into
something that you realize like i don't
know what to do here but i know that i
will find a solution that will that will
make me want to come back um
sorry you're talking about like only to
the past
yeah like you know just you encounter
like a wall you can't break or like a
waterfall that like you can see that you
can go through you're like why can't i
go through that waterfall like what what
is the thing i'm missing and then
eventually you find the tool and you can
do it again it's a lot like the metro
metroid formula um and i think those two
games share a lot in common but because
of their perspective people don't
usually yeah but they're very similar
it's interesting some folks in the chat
were saying that as well and saying how
recaller's game that seems to be sort of
taking some ideas from those as well and
applying them um a link between worlds
then i guess sort of an echo of a link
to the past 2013 game of the year for
gamespot.com as well it said such a good
job of distilling all those elements
that work for the traditional kinds of
zelda like include the first one uh
ocarina of time not at a time a link to
the past
but making it feel very fresh and modern
and i really love the way that it
approached dungeons that up to this time
we'd always thought of the dungeon is
like here's the place where i go and i
get the item and then i can find the
next dungeon this one was basically you
have all the items you have all the
tools that you need right in front of
you explore and do whatever you want
with those
there was such a
fun way to exp
to change up that formula
uh briefly let's talk about some of the
the stinkers what was the game maybe
like okay number one explicitly bad
games i'm guessing those cdi yeah the
hand what hand of fate wand
was that the was it the cartoon or was
it that was the will excuse me princess
that's from one of those games that was
from the cartoon oh i think the art
style is similarly is even worse like it
makes the cartoon look good which is
mind-boggling like i don't even know who
could have greenlit this like no one at
nintendo was like this is a good idea
yeah but someone had to have made this
and drawn all of this and gone like
let's make another game this is so much
fun and cool the voice acting is awful
and it's atrocious i bet i was like lost
in translation or something where they
just didn't have the good people
nintendo of america or something keeping
an eye over it and yeah and they did a
lot of drugs
look at there had to be mushrooms
something excuse me drug dealer um and
then i guess games that sort of maybe
didn't reach the high water mark set by
the game when i was younger i did not
like zelda two oh here it is look
actually yeah this is yeah oh it's just
so look at that jesus christ it's like
it's embarrassing like that's the kind
of drugs freddy krueger if you made it
you're like i'm not gonna put that in my
resume that is free is that his bong
your bong now
god it's just
awful yeah i couldn't wrap my head
around it's all the two either it was so
i mean the first game was kind of obtuse
anyway but this one was just like
it was such a departure that anything
that i thought i'd learned from the
original game was just thrown out the
window like on the overworld map the
first time i remember running into an
enemy
and then it transported me to this like
2d perspective it was just like
how does that make sense like before i
was engaging in the moment with that
enemy now i'm put into a level that has
multiple enemies
just because i ran into one on the map
it was so strange it was more for me it
was because of the challenge like i was
not used to that kind of gameplay and it
was a very challenging game it was very
punishing like if you screw up you're
going back to the beginning like wow
that was
it was almost a roguelike in that sense
where you have to know what you're doing
and get through it in the number of
lives that you had
for me like i don't think i could have
beat the ending when i was a child
without nintendo power i don't know how
you would have thought like you have to
turn into a fairy and then fall through
this very specific bridge that go
through a keyhole and you have a
specific lightning spell that you need
to use against the final enemy or else
it's not going to do anything because
that spell never does anything else at
any other point in the game like what
really
beautiful and it's not my favorite
especially in an age before the internet
uh 30 years long time uh last one on
this luna 9 in the twitch chat saying i
was so lucky that ocarina was the first
game i've ever played back when i was
four or five to which prepared death
says wow 405 makes me feel old 30 years
to 30 more years to sell this thanks so
much for coming in peter you're going to
stick around for a little while justin
you're off to dice right now you got to
get on a jet plane all right i have the
jet is waiting right outside the game
spot offices yeah helicopter that's
definitely how that works who you flying
with
southwest great will that be a fun
experience for you oh yeah yeah yeah
southwest you can enjoy it the bus of
the skies great thanks to sarah
yeah there's a ringing endorsement uh
thanks so much justin we'll get you
pretty soon eric tay get your ass in
here uh we got eric uh since we're gonna
talk about destiny and we're gonna talk
about the division and stuff because you
don't know anything about those peter
not really idiot
there's some truth to that
did you play that's the division beta
last week no i couldn't i just too busy
i don't have time to play everything
that i probably should yeah that's why
we have more than one editor person
reviewing video games here eric what's
up what up how you doing doing all right
how was your weekend it's okay this is a
three-day weekend i i tweeted out
yesterday morning that i woke up
panicking like oh god i'm late for work
oh wait
it's president's day that was awesome
really i was dreading coming into work
on yesterday but and then thank god
beautiful yeah it's a weird thing to
hear that there's so many of these bank
holidays that like nobody seemed to know
that we had monday off until like
thursday and yeah somebody mentioned it
i was like oh [ __ ] really
president's day is like one of the odder
holidays it doesn't really like
t-shock day prime minister day
in the uk
and we don't really have like a like a
type of meat that we eat on president's
day you know every holiday sort of has
like it's proteins
thanksgiving you got turkey christmas
you got ham oh really i guess oh it's
turkey for us
thanksgiving oh sorry we said that's
about fourth of july
barbecue of some sort right
hot dogs hot dogs cinco de mayo is is uh
carnitas
yeah
cinco de mayo pico de gallo
all right yeah we got all of them who's
your favorite president
uh i don't know lincoln
sure
wow
didn't see that coming
what about you peter
uh who's your favorite president if you
have to pick one
if i had to pick one i'm really not good
at the politics thing i've liked obama
so far i'm sure there's some things he's
done that i might not like if i knew
about them but yeah you know what by and
large he's been a good guy yeah there
you go good guy obama who's going to win
next
jeb bush trump jeff bush isn't going to
tweet now pictures of guns
with his name on giving him a hug in the
back of jesus christ
it's weird it's yeah the presidential
race right now is very strange it's like
a [ __ ] like i don't know anything
about america i don't know anything
about your politics i don't i don't
really either i've not lived here since
but man this looks like some crazy race
of
like very s divided people we're a
democracy but the crazy part about it is
these things called super delegates
which are uh
every every state has delegates and
super delegates and those really dictate
who gets elected president
delegates are for the most part beholden
to the popular vote of the citizens
super delegates don't have to do any of
that right so therefore we can rally
behind all these people all we want you
might say oh man trump is ahead in all
these polls but super delegates they're
gonna be like you know this guy's a
crazy [ __ ] he'll know the delegate
was good but the super delegate was a
much better console way better yeah so
yeah 16-bit 16-bit let's talk about
video games let's do it
before everyone just decides god because
all everyone's talking about bloody
politics it's gonna be yeah it's gonna
be 2016 is just a year of
click-baity goddamn political headlines
anyway
speaking of clickbait destiny 2 baby
it's coming out 2017 2017 we're going to
bring
some sort of large expansion pack in
2016. yeah good i wasn't sure if they
said fiscal 2016 or if they meant 2016 i
think they meant 2016 2016. i think it's
gonna be 2016. i would assume it would
probably be in that like
anniversary type range of like september
yeah when the kind of the game came out
originally so
taken king has done a really well for
them
by far the most popular expansion pack
25 million registered users jesus is a
good expansion yeah i mean it is the
expansion of fixed yeah i think a lot of
problems that people had right so
what do you want as somebody who like
has played a lot of destiny especially
last year you're kind of off the ball
like there's the content's not there
right now right like you're not playing
destiny right at the moment uh i did i
hadn't played for a while and then this
week i played a little bit uh because
they had an event they had like a
valentine's day event yeah they did
double xp no they don't have tables
partner but uh yeah but it it but uh it
was fun it it was uh 2v2 pvp was kind of
the the big stand out there but they
also have new emotes that you can spend
with microtransactions
including uh you know the strange dance
i think which is essentially hotline
bling oh really um yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then there's like the awkward
dance which is
uh napoleon dynamite so oh that's yeah
that's like some that's some
2004 world of warcraft elf [ __ ] sure
yeah exactly i guess they already own
the animation yeah but uh just drag and
drop right that's how it works exactly
but i played a little bit uh two years
ago probably two days worth yeah exactly
uh but yeah it was it was fine uh i'm
not
playing it like i used to uh but then
again part of the reason too is my raid
group stopped playing right it was kind
of the weekly we would get together and
we would play so that's why these things
matter right these like temple releases
because then you're like all right we're
back in right now yeah but there's also
the problem of when people quit and they
were already kind of starved for content
and kind of getting bored
it's harder to bring them back it's true
you got to keep them on that sugar you
got to keep
fresh supply in their bloodstream at all
times like i'm struggling to potentially
get one of my raid members to come back
whenever this expansion comes out
because he's like i think i'm just done
yeah and and then my other and then the
other raidmates like oh yeah you know if
you get him to play i'll play two but
only if he plays and it's like great now
i have to do this weird friendship
managing thing where it's like all right
i guess if i want to raid with these
guys again i gotta go you want to go see
them film but it's not a really good
film it's kind of a shitty one and but
like if you can just get like one of
your friends and go like who else is
going yeah
i had the hardest time getting people to
go see magic mike xxl oh really
that was not a good movie
did you see his pecs i love the first
one
like i genuinely you see you're joking
aren't you i have not seen either one
god but now everyone knows that you have
hook line and sinker i'm okay with that
i'm comfortable with my masculinity if i
heard that movie was funny i would go
see it but
the first magic mic is genuinely good
movie it is yes you're the first person
who's ever said that to me okay if you
go in with with
low enough expectations magic mike is
it's a surprising movie it's not what
you think it is kind of the second one
is exactly what you think it should have
been
anyway sorry too much magic mike
happening um diablos x says eric already
planning the week-long flu to have
around the game's release please are you
looking forward to
are you looking forward to like
a new expansion pack are you more
looking forward to like a destiny sequel
um
i think just because i don't know if i'm
used to it now i am looking forward to
an expansion especially if it sounds
because it sounds like it's going to be
probably as big or somewhat close to
taking king size not so much those
smaller ones that they did release in
which case that means there's going to
be a raid they're kind of done with
those ones right the smallest yeah it
seems like those are done because
they're doing these little events like
wow esque i guess in a way but it sounds
like it's going to be a little bit
bigger
probably because it has to be bigger it
has to make it until destiny 2 right it
has kind of got to keep your interest
for a little bit yeah
so looking forward to the raid i mean i
think that's the funnest part of destiny
it's still one of the
kind of the obstacles though for them a
little bit because they don't have a
system in place where if you don't
really know people to play with you know
to experience that but if they have all
the single player stuff too i'm looking
forward to it and i don't need to take a
week off because i'll be playing in the
office there you go the beauty of
working at gamespot.com yeah we were
very lucky uh yeah so do you think
they'll have to add eventually some sort
of ability to group up with randoms
because it doesn't seem like a bit like
if
like they had that core group of people
who were playing all the time so if it
does become a little bit more disparate
i don't know the mechanics of these
communities but
it seems to be something that enough
people are calling for right yeah i mean
the interesting thing is right now there
are tools but they're not within the
game right there are like websites and
stuff you can use
basically reddit as well yeah but uh
they generally work out and most of the
time surprisingly the people aren't
dicks and there's been a surprising
amount of community strength in terms of
people that sherpa other people and
they're really good about it like live
streamers and whatnot
but yeah hopefully and
hopefully by destiny too i don't think
by this expansion you're going to see
anything like that i would i would hope
that by destiny 2 there's some type of
in-game mechanic because they already
have
kind of matchmaking type stuff and they
do have numbers behind your character
right so they can probably take that
math and say okay well you're within
this range this is fits the
raid range you guys should be able to
play together and class specific type
thing hopefully i don't know we'll see
and i guess last point on this for
destiny 2 whatever they end up calling
the thing what does that game need to be
does it need to be like a similar slice
of gameplay but just like new maps new
areas new story new campaign or do you
want like
a burning crusade type of like game that
takes what's there already
adds more like sort of quality of life
stuff maybe connects it up a little bit
more fluidly uh like what is it that you
want particularly are you happy with
what's there would you be happy with
that like disappearing and going to one
side and like a new game appearing or
would you want would you like to keep
that is it important that that sort of
stuff remains and that there's more
layered on top um i think
it would be nice to see
maybe like two more new planets or
something like that i think that the
game's always going to revolve around
some of the stuff that's already there
it does a pretty good job of that now
um there's all these areas that you know
people walk through and then they're oh
this is part of dlc or something and
then they expand on it and they're like
oh that's pretty cool you know they do a
good job of
all these like the scenery and stuff
like that is beautiful it's a thing that
i don't think enough people talk about
you can walk around and you can see
something and remember that and have a
memory of that but
i think i i want them to build upon the
world that they have now i really want
them to kind of go
even more so towards the story that
they've kind of
slowly have fixed a little bit now with
taken king and i think if i read the
news today they got i think bungie has
hired the mass effect andromeda guy or
person their story
i think i think um and hopefully that
person helps create a you know bigger
story for destiny
yeah i think or dinklage let's just
[ __ ] double down on that guy yeah
let's see uh thank you so much eric
taylor destiny expert
i guess
really appreciate it uh folks in the
chat chiming in as well burgers be
saying a huge raid would be very cool
team toaster wants destiny 2 to be a
prequel let us know what you want at a
destiny 2 in the comments below
gentlemen
there's so much like random ass news got
dropped over the past two days uh the
latest thing to talk about is fallout 4
the expansions bethesda have come out
and
basically outlined the next three months
worth of dlc that they've decided to put
out like there was a bunch for fallout 3
broken steel the pace point lookout that
mothership zeta thing and right now
they've announced three different packs
they're coming out march april may uh
the first one march is coming at some
time of march uh automatron ten dollars
apparently there's hordes of robots
everywhere you go and kill them there's
this big one called robobrain which you
have to kill and then you can basically
construct your own sort of robot out of
parts you find in the world which is
pretty cool uh the wasteland workshop
one is coming in april then it's five
dollars
that seems to add just a bunch of stuff
into workshop designs you can capture
raiders and death claws and sort of
traps and then a bunch of like additions
to various aspects of the creation stuff
and then the big one far harbor coming
out is sometime in may that's 25
it's a some sort of nick valentine
quest off of that where you basically
travel off to somewhere off the coast of
maine there's a place called bar harbor
is that right apparently so like
probably a play on that um yeah we
travel off the coast of maine to a
mysterious island uh where higher levels
of radiation have created a more feral
world and navigate through the growing
conflict between since the children of
adam and the local townspeople will you
work towards bringing peace to far
harbor and at what cost so that's all
coming out at the moment these
thirty dollars
i guess season pass still applies all
that stuff adds up to 40 but actually
the season pass because they sort of
went and there's more stuff coming out
after these packs but they've also said
that um they're going to release they're
going to put the season pass up to 50
bucks at the end of the month i guess so
a lot of stuff there 30 bucks right now
50 bucks three of those coming out lots
more coming out for the rest of the year
they're also going to do closed betas
which you can opt into to get all this
stuff early if you want um peter you're
a big fallout 4 fan you enjoyed playing
the game you reviewed the game for
gamespot.com as well indeed uh what do
you think about this in terms of their
dlc strategy we've always known the bdlc
coming out for this or assumed uh does
this stuff excite you
which of the three sort of excites you
the most uh the bar harbor stuff sounds
really interesting to me because i
definitely found the the stories that
were a part of the fallout 4 experience
to be the most interesting aspect by far
that's what kept me going and kept me
like interested in the moment-to-moment
stuff
um i didn't get anything out of the
workshop it didn't do anything for me
um i don't really care about that the
robot building aspect sounds kind of
interesting but i'm curious like how
deep that goes and to what
extent that actually like has an impact
on the rest of the game you're playing
or if it's some just like
thing off to the side yeah you know like
oh here's a little robot mini game type
thing you can do well bethesda a lot of
4x4 had stuff off to the side
that never really impacted like the
settlements yeah like i enjoyed doing
that stuff because for whatever reason
just ocd or just like tinkering with
things but it is like a very divisive
part of the game like plenty of people
didn't didn't enjoy it did you do any
other stuff eric uh i did very little um
because definitely at the time when we
were you know giving stuff up to do
um was it on my priority list i don't i
guess i don't care about that it's just
it's a strange thing you like the
shooting more right now shooting and
looting baby uh
see that the tone in his voice yeah yeah
yeah heaven your step but um and
everyone in chat is like yeah of course
eric likes a loot game
uh but yeah the settlement stuff didn't
really do anything much for me the robot
thing like peter said sounds cool it
sounds like kind of like a small little
bite of you know
mission maybe like a couple missions or
something maybe just something to do off
to the side it kind of sounds like the
power armor a little bit uh what they
said here is choose from hundreds of
mods mixing limbs armor abilities and
weapons like the all-new lightning chain
gun uh even customize their paint
schemes and choose their voices so see
that's cool so that sounds like a thing
where you can actually develop something
within the game that makes a difference
yeah presumably like a
like a what you call them a partner like
a companion companion yeah basically
yeah exactly yeah but one that you can
really just go to town on i mean that
sounds good yeah the workshop stuff
seems pretty small all right like i mean
it's five bucks so it's probably going
to be pretty small and then yeah the far
harbor based on uh bar harbor we're
assuming that's like that reminds me
very much of what they did with point
lookout which was you get on a boat in
fallout 3 you go off to like an
archipelago
and there's like this big calvert
mansion is there and all like cool stuff
to do around there and it's kind of
enclosed within the world uh and that's
stuff always fun as well like when they
just let you go off somewhere and it's
like it maybe isn't necessarily
affecting all apparently there's gonna
be settlements in that part as well you
mentioned nick valentine was that just
sort of like a reference not like an
actual component i think it's it says
valentine's detective agency uh is where
it starts so i think maybe they got a
call okay instead of it just being like
a radio signal that pops up like that's
where the mission starts or whatever it
says it's the biggest landmass they've
ever put in an expansion wow including
uh including skyrim and the elder
scrolls section so yeah stuff sounds
cool is there anything so they've said
that those are the first three i'm sure
at e3 we're going to hear about what
they're doing for the rest of the year
30 bucks seems
pretty decent um considering what you're
getting and the the chances of more but
is there anything that you guys would
like to see that they sort of haven't
touched on here anything that you can
think that they could add to the game
which is kind of a difficult question
because a lot of that stuff you could
say would be mods at this stage racing
car racing
horse racing like the witcher
uh yeah i think uh if you know if
there's an opportunity to maybe expand
outside of boston which it sounds like
they're doing right i mean like that's
kind of all you can really do because
after you've played the game you've kind
of explored all of boston that they've
already given you i think it'd be weird
if they tried to add more within that
because that would change the context of
many things yeah but yeah like more side
story stuff because there's obviously
you know this one it's like it took
place i forget now it took place at the
same time as fallout 3 like slightly
slightly before yeah i mean there's 10
years before there's stuff happening in
the world around you outside of this
little city like so just keep telling
those stories and do it with the same
kind of care with characters and society
and building those things and fleshing
them out that's all for yourself
um
i don't know i
i mean i like that they're doing more
weapons and stuff like that i think
more fun stuff like that is always cool
i think it was funny watching
uh rob do like the the junk jet he's
just like oh yeah like bowling balls and
there's sports and stuff guys you might
never touch as well like the game is so
expensive already so maybe just fun more
fun guns and stuff like that but like
you said it's kind of hard because
those things are kind of like almost
like mods right they're starting to get
into that territory of like if it's not
a story or a mission or something like
that then it's kind of like yeah yeah
it's a strange one to try and plug in
all this stuff into a game especially if
you've got like completed a game like i
find it strange going back to the
witcher a little bit and doing more
quests considering how my game ended and
they literally say this is what happens
to the main characters and they're like
i'll just go back just chop some [ __ ]
heads off uh it's strange but uh there
you go i i guess last point on this what
do you guys think about the price um
forty dollars if you were to buy it all
separately and i mean that's hard to say
without seeing what exactly the stuff is
30 quid for a season pass
i mean it's going up to 50. you're
talking to the guy that buys destiny dlc
so as long as it uh
you know and if it's the biggest they've
ever added you know it sounds like
you're gonna have a lot of
you know main mission type stuff with
side story stuff so
sounds like it's a pretty good deal i
mean right if you want more fallout i
hate to equate like hours with value
right i spent 70 hours playing fallout
4.
and uh and i felt like i told you know
they provided us a copy of the game but
i got my theoretical money's worth out
of that
25 for an expansion however big does
seem a little bit pricey to me it would
have to be really substantial um and
something that i could spend a
significant amount of time with if i can
complete it in one like hefty sitting
like four or five hours
i would feel a little bit strange about
that yeah yeah the reason the cost of
the season pass is very strange to me
yeah it's it's it's almost like they
didn't expect that they were gonna make
as much stuff right and if you're maybe
doing that maybe good end the set a
project way and give it for free maybe a
little bit like the workshop thing
sounds a little bit like you could have
just gone there you go yeah it's almost
strange because then like if if they do
this right like i don't know any other
season pass that's gone up in price yeah
down the road i mean what's to stop that
from becoming a thing and then having
people worry that they need to purchase
the season pass as soon as possible
unless something like this comes up i
mean at least we're getting a warning
but it is a bit strange yeah i think uh
we've only got a couple of weeks left so
if you're interested in getting fallout
4 stuff go get the season pass i guess
or don't uh yeah figure it out maybe
some of the
the fallout 3 stuff was very hot and
cold as well like you could not bother
with motherships either maybe some
people like that one like that was kind
of okay um same with i guess was
operation anchorage as well which was
that was cool news all right so maybe
it's worth seeing what the reviews are
anyway let us know what you think in the
comments below if you're interested in
it if you're going to pick up the season
pass or if you're going to pick them up
individually let us know comments below
twitch chat i'm keeping an eye on you as
well do not worry everyone's talking
about the division like it's going out
of fashion though they can't wait to
talk about it um so i guess let's jump
right into it let's have a little chat
about the division uh the closed beta
was on was it two two weeks ago i
believe yes uh there's a new one coming
thursday february 18th this thursday on
xbox one and then if you want to play
the not shitty looking version uh you
can pick it up on pc
i'm so sorry microsoft
it does not look good on xbox one i'm
just saying it doesn't look that much
better on ps4 yeah you know the ps4 and
pc version is out then this friday a day
later february 19th uh it's gonna run
until 21st of the month that's the
sunday who knows though they push the
other one back a day so they could do it
again uh they've added
tech missions i guess the tech
side that way
yeah and then that big what is it like
the big sort of area that you own there
is like it's divided up into various
wings and then the tech one was
previously closed so they're going to
open up some new missions like i said so
you're probably going to save someone
like you saved someone in the medical
mission it's going to open up uh it's
it'll open up some new skills as well
probably not too much because in the
closed beta you're only really able to
get i think two medical skills and then
kind of like perk one of them but at
least you'll get to do that
uh but yeah
tech wing maybe there'll be a third beta
with a security wing probably not though
because the game was all out i know yeah
we're pretty close only a month to go uh
they've also
we talked a lot about the dark zone a
couple of weeks ago and sort of how it
worked and why it didn't work and there
was like very interesting sort of things
at play there but it didn't really feel
like it was clicking particularly right
so they've added a lot of sort of
incremental touches to it uh there's new
high-end weapons available in there the
refresh rate on the chests has been
greatly reduced uh non-player enemies in
the dark zone have been significantly
increased in number and non-player
enemies and dark zone have also been uh
buffed slightly so they're they're doing
a lot in comparison to that stuff um and
then some other bits and bobs the
manhunt timer now pauses instead of
refreshing when the combat uh is a level
five rogue so it's all very like again
yeah they're definitely tinkering before
release i think dark zone is
a major point of interest for them
because it seems like you know that's
going to be
when it's like their main pvp is
actually basically right it could i
don't want to guess but it could be end
game too you know you never know because
all the best all the best guns are in
there like i
i'm curious if you'll ever find a
high-end gun in a mission right i
haven't seen one you know i've seen blue
drops and stuff like that but haven't
seen high end uh but yeah it'll be
interesting it's i'm glad they're
populating the dark zone more because
you could run for a while and not yeah
anything but other people and then
everyone's kind of running to these uh
points of interest like the library or
like the the sports store where
everyone's trying to fight over the you
know whatever ai is there because that's
where you're going to get your drops to
kind of get uh to get them out of the
dark zone and extract them out of this
yeah it felt like players were having
like they were engaging with other
players almost out of boredom sometimes
that it was like yeah people were being
way more aggressive than they normally
would except there's no one else to
shoot so [ __ ] it i might as well shoot
this person instead especially because
like there's hardly there's not really
that much if you haven't picked anything
up there's nothing stopping you from
just going in and trying to shoot
everyone right yeah there's nothing you
know you're not gonna lose anything it's
definitely another thing they're
probably gonna have to look at and and
like you said they are tinkering the
rogue system but going rogue is fun uh
especially like you said if you have
nothing to lose you're well you're
always going to lose something like
you'll lose money and experience but if
you're not carrying any items then you
know what's to stop you from growing
uh game delay in the twitch chat says
devs have said that you can get high-end
weapons in missions but they're
significantly more likely to drop in the
dz
so yeah there's some stuff in there uh
yeah it should be interesting i'm
wondering what it's going to be like
when more people get involved that was a
closed beta before it did seem a lot of
people were in
yeah it seemed like i wasn't like
overwatch where it seems mostly like
it's price and streamers and then some
extra people but it seemed like there
was a yeah there's a fair amount of
people in there uh it's hard to say
because i don't know if the dark zone
areas if they're locked to you know like
almost like server type things where
there's like 20 to 30 in this dark zone
there's another 20 to 30 in another dark
zone like you don't really have a gras
it's not like
destiny where you're in the tower even
though that technically has a cap of
people but you see you know like 30
people or something like that other than
that you see like strays here and there
you're like oh yeah hey hey bud you
doing the same mission i'm running there
too i'm sure why are you shooting me why
you shooting me
yeah yeah um it should be interesting to
see anyway if you're interested in
getting us
you might want to start downloading
right now 27 gigabytes yeah you can
pre-load it you can you can play xbox
one yeah you can pre-load it on pc as
well oh nice i think
so i'm pretty sure okay because i'm i'm
already in there from the previous beta
so for me it's already it's up there so
test it out who knows or you can just
buy call of duty for 15 and play
multiplayer on that for a while i think
you get a good i think you'll get a an
a big enough slice of kind of what the
game is and how it feels to at least
know if you're going to want to buy it
yes they do lock a lot of the skills and
stuff behind like away like you can't
touch those and that looks like the more
in-depth stuff but i mean
like this this we talk about betas as
demos like how when we grow up it was
demos and cover discs and downloads but
like betas are becoming so much more
prevalent and obviously there is
technical reasons why they're doing this
i mean the fact that they've done all
these changes to the dark zone shows
that but this really feels like a game
that like i didn't know what this game
was until i actually
played it for five minutes i was like oh
god like okay and then after like two or
three hours it was kind of like you get
the feel for it um so i think it'll it
could definitely help you if you if
you're going to play this game and not
enjoy it you'll probably know pretty
quickly yeah i'm definitely still stuck
kind of in the middle how are you
feeling about it uh i'm interested for
sure uh i want to see all these other
later skills and how that changes things
i want to know what
like when i hit 20 or whatever i think
that's the max level potentially uh you
know what is the end game like is it
only the dark zone in pvp or is there
some kind of almost like raid-esque type
thing
um
that's what i'm more curious about the
the mechanics the shooting mechanics are
fine the cover mechanics are okay you
know what i mean it's like because some
people have problems with like everyone
in the chat's talking about the you know
bain one two two and hassan are saying
the only thing uh i've seen of the game
that bothers me is i hate spongy enemies
and that was one of the things that like
made me go
straight away and they're making them
more spongy yeah yeah dark souls
yeah yeah um it's it's i don't know
like when you snipe someone in the head
in in theory right you should be dead
but yeah you know that's not how video
games work so this video game works
yeah you just see a lot of numbers kind
of it's kind of like almost like wow
you're just like
and then it finally dies
yeah so i guess we'll find out later on
this week uh yeah let us know if you are
interested in playing the beta and
actually as well if you're watching this
uh maybe on gamespot or youtube in a
couple of days time once uh the beta is
live and you've played it let us know
what you think and we'll circle back to
this bad boy on next week's lobby peter
hi sorry i know you don't you didn't
really pay much destiny so i i was gonna
talk to you about that
the vision sorry i took a nap it's good
until you're refreshed
oh it's just an easy one okay a little
video game
it's been
six years since there's been a previous
one of that's actually a massive lie
there's been there's been a lot of
eight years actually but it's also a lie
because there's been a bunch of street
fighter 4's in the meantime but street
fighter 5 is officially out no as of
today really on pc you wouldn't know it
and home video gaming consoles
uh yeah like i said that's you know
it's been iterated on for years super
street fighter ultra arcade edition yeah
2012 updates and all that madness uh but
uh this is the first time this is the
latest i guess numbered version it is
the fifth street fighter game uh and you
have a review in progress up on the site
that's correct with good reason it seems
like you've held back on giving a final
uh score and a final assessment of it
speak to that first of all why why did
we not and
when will we see the final review up
there's a couple reasons uh primarily
though the game doesn't really have that
much single player content
um so you know if you're the type of
person who doesn't have a friend right
next to you you don't really have a lot
to do except train and maybe go through
survival mode the other option is
playing online but the servers were
really sporadic and fickle before launch
really and capcom was telling us oh no
this is part of the process we're
getting ready for launch
what you're experiencing now won't it
won't happen anymore
um
so i couldn't really review the game
because i couldn't say whether or not
online worked i didn't actually have the
real experience that a consumer would
have
and here we are on launch day thank god
we didn't put up a review because
servers are still having issues yeah so
it happens every once in a while
happened with um halo anniversary
edition i remember a couple of years
back with chris
i played some i tried to play some last
night had a bunch of connectivity issues
let's talk about one thing actually
first of all over the weekend um daigo
played
uh had a bit of a fiasco
himself uh he played a show
let me have one dad joke forever
part of capcom's i guess publicity for
the game
daigo played louis fiasco in showdown
just down the road actually yeah
actually i don't know i think it worked
out for in capcom's favor but it
definitely started more on twitter you
know lupe started to just he it wasn't
for this necessarily he just was
tweeting and facebooking about how you
know he plays a lot of street fighter he
grew up playing street fighter loves
third strike and
uh you know i think a madcast
representative who uh marc mann who no
longer isn't there anymore but anyways
they he got them to get the match right
and so now last night they played last
night lupe daigo uh lupe one three two
somehow uh i i'm sure because street
fighter 5 is a game where enthusiastic
casuals can come in and stand toe to toe
with the pros right well hey
i mean that's the marketing he did he
didn't look okay he did look like don
riker keeps beating jason a striker and
he plays like all the time so sometimes
when you can't did he give him the game
yes for sure yeah you can tell cause
like lupe did a lot of wake up dragon
punches and most pro players will catch
on to that let you do that punish you
severely he let him get away with that a
decent a good amount of time like a fair
amount of times and that's kind of a
sign of like yeah he's kind of he's not
blocking all the time and whatnot but i
will say to lupe's credit he's it's not
like
he doesn't know exactly what he's like
he's not he looked good he looked pretty
good like he had minimal training some
scrub coming in yeah he he only got 45
minutes or so to play uh to train a
little bit with combo fiend and you know
he you see you saw it right there he
just dragged points
and so
you know he he he he did pretty well but
at the same time you know like daigo
started to try to parry a lot of things
like instinctively he hasn't you know
played as much you know against someone
like luffy where he might just throw
something out so he he doesn't have all
the parry timings down but you could see
him
he's so jazzed to get one game maybe
he's throwing those parries like you
know with the incorrect timing just to
make it look like are we going to see
rematch at evo then um who knows well
they keep this stretched out who knows
man the rematch always makes more money
than the first one
yeah i guess so i mean diego is going to
be there so it's up to them if they want
to do the run-back wasn't the grammy's
better things to be doing uh anyway
let's get back on to the the review
obviously like the community with street
fighter is super important thing loads
of people tuned in and watched that last
night and also on the steam i guess
reviews at the moment the community are
really letting capcom have at it
especially in terms of the the
networking stuff uh what type of
networking problems did you have was it
just like well servers weren't weren't
up consistently i would i would turn on
my playstation 4 go on a pc and it would
tell me hey you need to make a fighter
id and it was like what about the last
five that i made right yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think you kept just wiping the
server so i've i have i've had no sense
of like ownership of a fighter and
progressing and earning experience and
all that and like and how that feels but
but even so like it's the the game is
it's pretty anemic right now yeah
there's not a lot too and i've heard on
the pc version i need to actually test
this today that you can't change the
button configuration so it actually will
preset it to a keyboard or if you plug
in a joystick it has to be a directx
supported joystick right or x direct
sorry or what will it work at all x
input right it doesn't do direct input
controllers so something that is
licensed by microsoft and fits within
their sort of like rpi yeah it will
automatically bind to that that sounds
crazy for people who spend like hundreds
on on off microsoft you know off-brand
well no i think i think most of those
most of those brands will work anything
that'll work on uh like an xbox for
example will be fine because that shares
that um x input library like i'm not too
good at fighting games but i always go
into the single player stuff when i do
them like i love street fighter 4 and
play through that with a bunch of
characters
the single player stuff in this is so
sparse like the the main campaign stuff
i haven't done all that much off that
seemed pretty small the challenges
section as well man i mean like you i
was like i'm not good at fighting games
but i was brazing through these
you're talking about the survival sorry
survival challenges are not a challenge
oh really and challenges will be the
thing that people play to have fun with
the game and become a better fighter
right you know and it's where capcom can
provide tutorials for specific
characters saying like this is why this
dragon punch is so-and-so or this that's
why you know this uh this v-trigger is
more special like they'll they'll inform
people how to play the game and in doing
that provide them a way to connect with
it not just become a better competitor
but to actually feel like you're you're
you're playing a game and growing you
know over time yeah right now it's like
okay you can train locally you can play
this super easy single player content
that is there or you can jump online
where you face the same concern
everyone's always faced with online
fighting games whereas you're gonna go
on you're gonna get your butt kicked
you're not gonna learn anything and
you're gonna feel embarrassed
and that's a really easy way to grow
distant from a game you know if all you
have is
playing against the cpu and playing at
someone who's going to destroy you for
the most part
what you know what's left yeah sort of
seems like they're on both ends of the
difficulty spectrum there as well i had
a weird situation yesterday sorry i
wasn't wasn't what was survivor mode
right
so that's the one against the ai right
yeah that's the one where you go for
like 10 rounds or 30 or 100 and you play
like different people who jump in is
that the one where you
uh i wonder if that's because i played
one where i basically like fought
somebody for one round and then it asked
me that i want to take a supplement
right next one that's survival yeah that
thing yeah so i did that and i killed
the last boss of that section i think
and the game like i guess it was trying
to like register that i'd done it on the
network and it [ __ ] crashed back to
the main menu so i was like what i just
killed all these dude and then boom it's
it's worse than the scenario you paint
it's not i mean it's still bad it's not
that the game is trying to at the end
connect to the server and say something
when you have the sort of fight request
stuff turned on or you're just connected
to capcom fighters network
and you're playing survival mode if
there's a problem with the server at any
point it will kick you out really i got
to fight like 26 out of 30.
over the weekend the servers went down
sorry back to the main menu you lost all
that progress you have nothing to show
for it yeah furthermore if you're
playing offline because you're trying to
avoid that sort of thing you don't earn
fight money yeah all your kids fight
money is the currency you can only earn
fight money when you do things while
you're connected to the internet can i
spend money on five money uh you can buy
zenny
which is the real money currency
equivalent of fight money got it um and
for that you can spend six bucks to
unlock new characters and they come out
oh that's a nightmare um
what's interesting is like i find the
way fight money is distributed to be
very uneven um story mode incredibly
easy yeah i got through it doing the
same command just to see how easy it was
the same action for the entire thing
took less than an hour what did you do
uh pressing forward and hard kick all
right just repeatedly never did anything
different and i got through it um
there's no difficulty setting right
absolutely no difficulty setting um wow
and so the problem is you beat that and
you get 100 000 fight money and you're
like cool that's got a [ __ ] fat wad
of cash
meanwhile you go online right and you
struggle for three rounds you come out
on top you're like man that was that was
really hard that was a real test of my
skill yeah 50 fight money i wouldn't
wait
how much did you get is that a winner
that's a win you don't get any for a
loss 100 000
all this like every character every
every character but every single
character can be completed total
everything in less than an hour yeah
because they're it's just four
fights right
not for everybody
right one of them is two fang looks
shows three chapters the first two are
the only ones that are actual fights the
third part is just a storytelling
campaign
the first two fights of for fang are
both against m bison
oh wait watch both
who cares it doesn't it's so easy it
doesn't make any difference it is throw
away content and they try to provide
these back stories for these characters
in an entertaining way and it's like
kind of lighthearted and goofy like
where some of these characters put their
priorities right the art that's used to
present these stories looks so rough it
is so poor knowing what bengus the
artist behind it had done in the past
like i'm not allowed to say that i know
that he rushed it yeah give me a break
this this stuff is not the work of an
artist who sat down to render something
completely there is stuff that is
worse than a storyboard sketch
i mean it doesn't make sense and you
said in your review and progress and it
was exactly what i experienced last
night was that some of the stuff looks
like some look looks unfinished like
some of the frames look like way worse
than the next one there's no consistency
in quality no no no i know it's like
it's not that important on its own and
people might say we're nitpicking but it
sort of speaks to this
the whole package just feels like it's
not really that yeah the attitude behind
this game is exemplified in something
like those images yeah because for as
much as capcom is saying that they want
to make this and you know a clean slate
bring everyone else in they're releasing
this at a time so they can hit all the
tournaments so people who are fighting
in them have access to the game they're
leaving out modes that are for single
player you know or just for the more
casual audience which is the majority of
the audience
and then when they do go the extra mile
to give them something they don't even
finish the lap
yeah it
it it's really unfortunate because the
gameplay itself is really freaking good
i love all the systems that they took
away from you know they took out a four
and all the stuff they replaced it with
like
it feels great again like all these old
characters that seem so familiar they're
actually like different and i want to
play
old characters that i never cared about
before now because of how different they
are
um so playing it is really fun and when
i'm sitting next to someone it's great
but when i'm waiting for matches online
and it just takes so long to connect and
then i get disconnected and then i'm
just back in the main menu by myself in
my living room it's like you know what i
don't i'm going to play something else
there's nothing for me to do here unless
i want to fight against a cpu dummy ad
nauseam or
do the survival mode stuff and not earn
anything from my efforts because i'm not
online it sounds like a nightmare of a
game to try and review because like you
were saying people playing next to each
other like the desk beside me has had
richard and julio playing yeah a bunch
in fact they're going to be doing a
stream of street fighter 5 right after
the lobby so make sure you stick around
but
yeah like there's been people really
really enjoying this game in the office
but then when you get online it's like a
chalk and cheese kind of it's like it's
completely different what's been your
experience of it eric have you enjoyed
it have you played any online stuff
mostly been local i haven't played
online stuff i kind of started seeing
the tweets and stuff last night like oh
i can't log in i can't do this and that
so i've been playing in the office
because we've had it early which is you
know lucky for us of course again but uh
like like peter said i enjoy it i think
they've done a lot they've made a lot of
good strides in terms of the systems and
the mechanics that they've changed and
you know uh selected on and also again
just picking uh making characters that
were old kind of feel fresh and
different and even someone like me that
plays ken he plays totally different i
don't even know if i like his normals
anymore i might pick someone else he's
got the worst v skill in the game by the
way
what's this one you gotta you gotta uh
you we just gotta learn how to use it
right yeah he's the run skill uh it's a
run so he just runs forward and then has
a kick at the end no no you can do other
things though you can run cancel and
stuff oh you can so that's mind games
okay okay i can see that being yeah but
but it's like immediately yeah it's like
on paper yeah
but to
kind of hearken on that point yeah maybe
if the game
showed us what he could do with that
skill yeah
it's super important and street fighter
4 shipped with a lot of this stuff it's
just
yes as a beginner i felt straightforward
actually had my back yeah it was like
decent training mode which is kind of
half season it is so obvious how much is
missing for this game because of the
timing associated with its release and
that is really unfortunate because i i
want this game to succeed and at this
point i think it will like i think it
will catch up i you know i want more
characters and a lot of competitors
don't necessarily like a bigger roster
yeah and i can understand why because it
it makes it harder for you to understand
all the match-ups but it also dilutes
the you know who's special and for what
reasons but at the same time it also
provides more variety for people who
maybe they're bored with one character
right they're not hardcore competitors
they want to play this other person
but even for competitors it gives them
more challenges too yeah so they need
that they need the story mode that
provides a better representation of the
world and these characters because let's
be honest street fighter is a series
that's been around for a long time it's
earned a an incredibly valuable legacy
and it's and it hasn't handled it
properly so if it can do that it really
can be substantial and feel special but
it's going to take months
and uh i i don't know i think charging
60 bucks is too bad a lot of people on
pc were able to pick it up for like 30
percent off
yeah they're those weird
europeans companies with their uh yeah
with their
cheaper uh pc code or whatever but
um that stuff's coming in june though
right i mean not that i want to give
them a pass that like and it kind of
sucks that you don't get a day one but
at least it's i guess coming this like
better story too i believe right yeah
it's supposed to be like like really an
hour or two of cinematics you know it's
a 3d in-engine stuff
um from some of the things i i watched
during like a preview event a while back
they had a short trailer it was fine it
looks good um but but really it's the
it's the secondary activities it's the
challenges the trials like all that
stuff that really
lets you interface within the game with
the game in a different way but dude
there's not even an arcade mode where
you can just know so that's immediately
what i go for as well and i was like i
spent it was like i remember the only
other time i felt this way was when i
bought battlefield vietnam and it said
there was a campaign in the back of the
box and then there was no campaign i
spent like five minutes on the menus
being like where the [ __ ] is arcade mode
you can't even play versus mode against
cpu yeah yeah yeah you know like these
are basic things that have been in
fighting games
forever which don't seem like they take
all that
it's got survival mode yeah yeah if it's
got survival mode why not
tweak that a little bit and make it
arcade mode like it's
it's not that difficult it really isn't
and i i don't know if they thought that
like survival mode would be a good
replacement but like you said it's super
easy you can buy these supplements by
trading in points there's no challenge
yeah it doesn't feel fulfilling no we're
like i never needed a supplement yeah no
exactly you don't even need it yeah i'm
not even like good at these games yeah
but like man remember the arcade modes
were like okay the first fight was easy
second place a little bit harder and it
keeps ramping up and then you get to a
boss or you're just like damn [ __ ]
seth yeah exactly
i the street fighter is it lacks like
the the spirit that so many people
attach themselves to yeah
the competitors have what they want but
mainstream does not it's weird hey when
do you think you're gonna post a review
yeah it's a real tough one it sounds
like in one it's it does so much so
right in in this way but the same game
for two different people who play it for
different reasons is like a completely
different experience right yeah i mean
for me i'm i'm ready to sort of give my
opinion on all that but what i need to
do is actually give the the game a
couple days yeah uh to play on the
servers because i've been able to get
online today i've also been booted today
you know if if it can become stable by
tomorrow let's say that'd be great and
that'd be really good to know because i
don't want to publish a review one day
saying the servers suck and then capcom
is like hey we figured it out yeah um at
the same time i need to also test the
netcode when it's at its best because uh
street fighter 5 uses a feature called
rollback i forget exactly how it works
technically but essentially it'll go
back in time after
uh
missing some uh some frames you know and
with with low ping uh and that can
create some really dramatic problems
when you're fighting at least it did for
me like a lot of the teleporting around
the screen to where i was just hoping i
knew where i was going to be at a right
at the right moment when it caught up to
the past and like yeah it doesn't work
so i need to make sure that you know
that stuff is optimized as well so i
think uh
definitely by saturday morning um
hopefully by friday cool i'll have my
full review all right thanks so much a
lot of people in the twitch chat talking
about the problems they've had with
connecting as some other people have
sort of had better issues mundus
six says i've been playing all day today
and last night perfectly every one of my
friends who plays on pc hasn't had any
problems all that play on pc ps4 are
though they can't play and i had
problems on pc last night i've heard
some people have yeah i think
if you're lucky you're lucky it's like
if you got in you're lucky you know like
sometimes it works out for some people
sometimes it doesn't so for sure uh yeah
so we're gonna attempt to do a stream of
this in a couple of minutes time right
after the lobby so make sure you stay
tuned here if you're on the twitch uh
channel it'll be happening immediately
afterwards if you are watching on
gamespot i would imagine you have to go
back to the homepage and click on the
now playing link i'm pretty sure oh yeah
so that'll be the case uh yeah that's
pretty much a show one last thing i want
to touch on it's not really a big enough
section to talk about in its own right
but um
last week microsoft came out with some
interesting news about i guess some mic
some xbox one fans weren't happy that
alan wake was getting a day and date
release on pc sorry
oh my god quantum break so close
quantum black
it's a me what's his name again mario no
not mario
that definitely was a mario accent
he's the lead guy in remedy again
it's me sam blake i know it's now it
sounds like mario and i'm going to show
you some gameplay for quantum break from
alan wake it's the same thing
sure it
okay come on and max pay it doesn't mind
yeah uh at least yeah they said not
naming a game after somebody's name this
time uh but yeah so that's coming out on
on pc uh but what they also announced
was that that and gears and a couple of
other ones are coming out on pc but
they're not coming out on steam yeah
it's windows 10 right yeah they're going
to sell them in the windows 10 micro
[ __ ] micro
micro micro store i was about to call it
they should have called it that and said
um
in a weird way this shouldn't be news
because there's nothing forcing people
to put anything on steam it's a
third-party piece of piece of software
but like i
hardly ever play games that aren't on
steam like i [ __ ] hate opening origin
like it's a nightmare yeah do you
remember your password do you have the
access code for this machine
you need two references personal
references before we exactly no
i just might as well be the i just put
the steam authenticator on this guy yeah
because i'm some worried about docket
thing uh but yeah what do you think
about what that does that
i i feel like this is just a big
fanboyism [ __ ] conversation like it's
just people pissed that they don't get
to use team i prefer to be on steam but
like it's not really that much of a big
deal unless there's some sort of like
money tied to content that's specific to
one platform or another and there's like
a disparity there and people are getting
gypped
i don't i don't see the issue here yeah
i i i don't maybe it maybe i'm maybe
there's something i'm missing the one
thing i don't like is that
this we may be in a you know activision
call of duty situation although their
games are on steam but like there may be
an issue where like the best thing about
steam is that stuff goes down in price i
remember the problem now what's the
problem is there any online associated
with this game with quantum break yeah i
don't think there's any multiplayer but
there probably will be some sort of dlc
gears on the other hand yes definitely
so you have to pay for xbox live to play
those games oh
you're right that might be the issue
okay i could see that yeah that changes
it a bit yeah yeah i mean i don't want
to have to spend money to play gears of
like years of war but you would have i
guess the new one i guess maybe yeah i
guess that's true i was gonna say you
would have played on xbox one anyways
but then maybe not either if it was on
steam yeah it's interesting how much
they're gonna roll into this because you
can see that
this may just be a
like the xbox one's about selling like
half as many as playstation 4 this may
be a case of them being like look you
know we want remedy to sell some games
here we want our gears game to sell not
just on this like tiny little install
base so it makes sense for them
monetarily but it does kind of take a
little bit of the sheen off the xbox one
if like all their big
you know exclusives are essentially
coming out on the biggest platform ever
i think microsoft is shooting themselves
in the foot by staying committed to the
xbox one brand oh really you're going to
like me before i finish i i thought i
thought you were saying something else
yes i thought you were going to go with
by not being on steam
no i thought you were going to go by
putting these on pc at all on the same
time
well maybe in the short term but i think
in the long term microsoft is
it would behoove them to unify their
platforms sell just sell things that are
called xbox that run windows steam
machines sure i mean call them whatever
the hell you want they've already
figured it out but but they essentially
have two markets and they're trying to
juggle them one they're losing the other
one they're really losing
which ones am i talking about you don't
know
no i know right but they but they but
they could seriously like join their
effort together and sure maybe even keep
the console thing and make it low spec
and affordable so can still run the
games that come out on pc but unify that
stuff own the space that you have your
fingers in but are not committing to as
like one big unit you think like
ultimately that's just gonna be the
future anyway in like three four years
really should i mean they're hinting at
sort of unifying those those platforms
in one way or another they might just
mean in terms of community and accounts
i think that's kind of already a thing
yeah but
dude it would make so much sense if they
could dominate those two spaces
interesting stuff all right let's wrap a
show a bunch of stuff this week thank
you so much we talked about black ops 3
we've talked about zelda turning 30
destiny 2 uh the 5 expansion packs
divisions beta street fighter 5 and
microsoft so much stuff happening video
games man they're super popular thank
you so much for watching this show uh
live here on twitch and on gamespot for
watching the on the map versions of
course you can watch the full show at
any time uh on gamespot immediately
afterwards pretty much uh to folks who
watch this on youtube apologies when it
goes up as a
on-demand video on youtube there's
always like this 10 minutes of [ __ ] at
the front that's basically so we can get
it up like immediately without having to
wait like a day or so
and then that's why we trim it down
after a couple days because we get to
render it and if you're listening to
this on itunes thank you so much for
listening we hope you've enjoyed it hope
it sounds good let us know what you
think of come down to the comments and
comment there hit me up at daniel dwyer
and if you want there and also please
rate and review us on itunes let's get
some more ears on this show that'd be
super fun uh thank you so much again for
supporting the show really appreciate it
thank you peter brown thank you eric tay
thank you justin haywald who is flying
over us right now
waving down
uh and thanks to everyone in the
production uh booth as well uh big
thanks to josh shaw
and to mary kay she was running
tricaster today as well uh stay here
julio is gonna be playing uh richard
gonna be playing street fighter 5 live
right here on twitch if you're on
gamespot back out to the homepage and
you'll see a link to it and we will see
you next time tuesday 2pm pacific right
here on gamespot.com see you then
you